me
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to actinflab live
stream number
33.0 it's november 18th 2021
welcome to the actin flab everyone
we are a participatory online lab that
is communicating and mute if you're not
going to be speaking thank you we're a
participatory online lab that is
communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at the links here on this slide
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us all with
feedback so that we can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here
we'll be following good video etiquette
for live streams and respecting our
awesome facilitator blue
at this short link you can find the
streams past and upcoming and we are
about to be heading into the second half
of november 2021 where on the 23rd and
the 30th we'll have two participatory
group discussions on this very paper
we're going to discuss today thinking
like a state
and then we have yet to set the december
papers so if you know someone who might
be interested in joining or you yourself
would like to discuss a paper of yours
get in touch with us
today in active stream 33.0 the goal is
to learn and discuss this paper thinking
like a state
embodied intelligence in the deep
history of our collective minds by aval
guinin kalu
and the video like all
zero videos even though we do have the
author here it's just an introduction to
some of the ideas
and how to pronounce them not a review
or a final word so we'll introduce
ourselves and then go into aims and
claims abstract and roadmap
keywords figures and formalisms etc so
let us know especially if you'd like to
participate in the upcoming 33.1 and
33.2
we'll start with just an introduction of
saying hello and what we're excited to
talk about or resolve either in the dot
zero or in the upcoming group
discussions
and then we'll culminate with the author
and transfer facilitation over
so
i'm daniel i'm a researcher in
california
and
i'm just excited to
check in on the progress of this
important topic people have been
theorizing about societies and cities
and states and everything in between
since as long as they were there
probably a little bit before
so it's just a fun topic and i'm really
excited to see how active inference can
give a new lens at resolving some of the
long-standing questions in that area
i'll pass it to stephen
yeah thank you daniel um
i'm steve and i'm based in toronto and
uh
i'm really interested in the multi-scale
implications of
state and
niche construction particularly for me
because i'm interested in working around
what i call social topographies which is
probably at the scale of
events and moments in people's like
lived experience and in their
architectures and places so i i'm really
excited that this is bringing in this
idea of state
and larger scale but also bridging that
with
active inference from the kind of
faster smaller scale so yeah lots of
good stuff here lots of ontological
questions as well which i think is
really cool
um and uh i passed it over should i pass
it over to blue blue or sharp yep over
to you
so i'm blue i'm an independent research
consultant in new mexico and i really
like this paper
and i really like working and talking
with avell about ideas because these
ideas are kind of at a bigger scale
i am interested in self-assembly of
things like at the cellular and maybe
even subcellular level and like this
takes it to the very big level and i
think that active inference really kind
of unifies this it's a skill-free
framework and so that's kind of what i'm
excited to talk about today and maybe
not resolve but discuss and get some
other perspectives on um and i'll pass
it to the first author of the paper or
the only author of the paper avail if
you'd like to just introduce yourself
say a few words
so i'm
available
i have a training in collective science
and physics mainly i'm interested in
philosophy and a lot of things
what we learned here is that i funded
and helped organize cairo's research
participative citizens laboratory which
aim is to understand
how to act or to navigate
contemporaries and show historical
dynamics
and part of this is to understand
why we have states and
how those states that we now have are
like
um
so the goal of the paper is to basically
understand how states have constituted
and what it tells about their continued
structural identity through ages and
this
of course the topic is big there are
several kind of states but the very
first thing we need to do is to
understand what your state is
and where it comes from and that's what
i'm trying to do there
awesome so moving on to the aims and
claims of the paper
uh so this paper thinking like a state
embodied intelligence in the deep
history of our collective mind
in the paper it states that the core
argument of this article is that states
can be and should be understood as
hierarchical control systems essentially
similar in their core physical
architecture to brains
and we will leverage active inference to
ground the study of intelligence in the
way an organism maintains their
structural autonomy to formally assess
the collective brain hypothesis
and the big question of the article
is what kind of intelligence is
displayed by city-state systems
and how is it embodied in their
structure
so we'll go through the abstract daniel
do you want to take the first section of
the abstract
yeah stephen first
oh just one comment just because i know
you mentioned kairos there and
i've done an activity with the kairos
blanket
or it's like a mapping
thing where you stand on parts of canada
and to look where it came from so i
don't that connects to i if i'm writing
you kairos is
working at that kind of regional
national scale to look at
questions around that and
from what i hear that's informing
how your research is
being approached is that correct
i did not understand the question um
not correct
yeah it was an activity it's an activity
actually not to do with a fristen
blanket literally where they put a big
blanket um about
parts of canada on the floor in a room
and then people have to stand on it and
they keep taking away bits
which were basically um
which which were not are no longer
in the territories of the first nations
and then you see how much is left
there's not a lot left
so to speak so it's talking to that idea
of statehood and
settlers and how much is left and i
wonder if that speaks to the wider work
of kairos and
questions of states and how do we
understand how we fit into that or maybe
i'm i'm mis
misunderstanding
so that fits in the work of keros
because it uh tries to bridge scales
i never heard of these keras broadcast
this is not related to what we do in any
environment it helps embody an
impression of how well settlers have
appropriated
indigenous american territories so this
is something that's
called that fits the mandate of karus
but the core
idea of keroses
it's the greek notion uh for time for
three in a greek and carlos is the
instant uh and it's uh coded
actively like it's an instant where you
can see the opportunity
and um this is basically what embodied
agents do they build skills and they
build capabilities and they enact them
when it separates this is the goal of
chaos to understand and reproduce uh
this uh core ability and
a lot of people have used kerosene you
have anarchists
that claim um that are called cairos you
have a christian concept that is called
cairos you have a lot of people that
make the use of the concept because it's
very broad and it's very um
it's not something that has been
imported in the
christian concept of times really in
like what you have today so if you want
to talk about this you use you just use
the greek word which is kairos so
yep just one thought then i'll go to the
abstract which is that kairos as opposed
to kronos like a chronometer with
decimal time kairos is like timeliness
and it brings action and sort of
a little bit of a moment that transcends
the tick tick tick tick tick so it's a
cool term
i'll read the first
third of the abstract
this article aims to show how the deep
history of early state societies entails
the development of a collective form of
cognitive agency
it relates classical works in the
anthropology of states
in particular scots seeing like a state
with the inactive account of biological
and cognitive organization thanks to the
unified ontology for self-organization
dynamics across scales offered by the
active inference framework
stephen do you want to take the next
piece of the abstract
yes
okay
so active inference conceives of
cognition
a synchronization across individuated
sensory motor states
it entails that biological or
sociocultural constraints display
minimal form of cognition by shaping the
behavior of faster dynamics in a certain
way
when such constraints collectively
define a basic life form
an integrated operationally closed
system
they can therefore be said to embody
adaptive knowledge properly speaking
and then i'll just take the last part it
says the inactive inference account i
articulate here strongly motivates and
methodologically grounds a hoist
a holist approach in the social sciences
indeed it grounds the study of human
societies in the role of structural
constraints whose meaning depends both
on the broader systems activity and in
the historical context of their
emergence
the present account of the dynamics of
early urbanization and state genesis
aims to illustrate this approach
and a quick just walk through the road
map of the paper we're gonna go through
the introduction section and then there
are three main sections of the article
the embodied intelligence in nested
minds is the first
the second is the deep history of cities
and states
the third from the urban metabolism to
the collective mind and then
we'll go through the conclusion
and first up in this
dot zero contextualization video we're
going to discuss the keywords which i
think there were no official keywords
but these are the words that i created
for the paper when discussing it
at the conference so we pulled out
intelligence
autonomy embody intelligence active
inference the free energy principle the
concept of thinking through other minds
and we've done that in a stream before
daniel is that true i think we have
right
um and then uh niche construction so i
don't know i don't have the facts on the
on the exact number of the thinking
through other minds um stream but we can
find that out somewhere during this
during this talk we'll look it up
um
so
evel do you want to maybe speak to we'll
give you the first stab at talking about
what you mean by intelligence and
autonomy we've pulled a couple quotes
out of the paper but maybe you'd like to
say a few words
so if i remember well intelligent
etymologically it's the capacity to make
links
to connect dots of data and to build
antiquity understanding of it
i don't want to commit to any specific
notion of intelligence because
i am not aware of any meaningful
first principle definition of it
there is a lot of work in measuring
intelligence like iq
which
maps to specific cognitive abilities and
has literally zero reason to generalize
to other life forms than humans
and we contribute to other life forms
than humans in occidental societies
the national autonomy is much more
specific it's important to uh
okay so etymological is one's ability to
build one's own rules so for example if
your city state has lows and
the organs that make the law are within
these states it is autonomous in a
strictest sense
it is also recruited in the study of
life and condition and the way cognition
is grounded in life
by inactivist scholars
where it is
related to a personal closure under
precarious consensus
so it is something that is
able to operate and able to recreate the
conditions in which in which it operates
while there is no uh exogenous force
that help himself do so
for example if you have a candle it
helps
there is a burning fire which uh
generates a flaw from season so as to
maintain itself but if someone does not
keep um
fuel going
this dies so this has no really way to
recreate the conditions at which it
operates this is in contrast to the
simplest bacteria there is which is able
to look for food basically
so the
active concept seeks to capture that
nice um daniel do you maybe want to read
the the quotes from the paper directly
referring to
um
intelligence and autonomy as described
er intelligence is the general ability
for a system to understand the world
either in a reflexive propositional way
or as enacted in their ecological
activity
and autonomy refers to the property of
operational closure under precarious
circumstance ie to the capability of
biological systems to continuously
maintain and recreate their own
structural identity as a result of the
collective activity of their
constitutive processes
right and these are processes that are
actively generating and sustaining
identity
and i think avell spoke really well to
operational closure um in the what you
just described but we just want to refer
anybody who's listening to
this paper by
monteville and massio in 2015 this
biological organization as a closure of
constraints as closure of constraints
so i want to emphasize
that there is i think it's pretty old
the percentage it has at least 10 years
and the monteville paper is an attempt
to formalize it in uh logics
so it is not necessarily the the
reference on this i don't remember what
is the reference paper on this
[Music]
awesome thank you
um maybe let's move on to embodied
intelligence and stephen if you uh this
is perfect for you if you want to read
the quote from the paper describing um
what embodied intelligence refers to
yes okay
embodied intelligence refers to the
ability for understanding
adaptation so sort of a mixture of both
that is imprinted in an agent's physical
structure rather than in some
general computational ability
yeah that's significant and then we have
the wood lice
alias yeah don't use the jitsi chat fyi
you can use key base if you want a back
channel
but that's the wood lice example that
carl firsten provided in the 2018
example that's a little shout out there
awesome
um
yeah so
the uh does anybody want to say a few
more words about embodied intelligence
maybe avel or steven or if there's
something that comes up for you guys
feel free to raise your hand
if there's something else you want to
discuss
and the slides are the slides that we
prepared avail for the
talk they're in the key based chat as
well
so i'll i'll mention just to say i mean
because we're kind of introducing at
this stage i won't start raising those
and loads of questions and
we'll save that for the the next one but
uh and i just note that um
that this is useful just to highlight
how this is being structured because
you've got this word intelligence
embodiment and
uh i know in the there's them talk about
the brain or the idea of the brain and
the idea of the mind
um so i think it's interesting here that
um
this this paper sort of bridges a bit
across
um the brain
intelligence mind culture kind of
uh area so when it's talking here it's
kind of seems quite an open description
um
and is um
really making sure it's clear to
speak to the difference to this general
computational ability
and that it's it's somehow a different
type of
uh knowing that's been done maybe with
the word you know morphological
computing sometimes is used in that in
that world
nice thank you
um maybe daniel do you want to
explain the free energy principle and
active inference
sure so
as on the slide here the free energy
principle states that dynamical systems
given sufficiently regular boundary
conditions which are required for their
continued existence
spontaneously self-organize so as to
minimize their expected variational free
energy through time
effectively maximizing evidence for the
world model they enact
so the expected variational free energy
which we talk about in more detail
elsewhere it's kind of like all aspects
of the system through time are what have
to
be handled in order for persistence
and
using some technical formalisms
that turns out to have
equivalence with evidence for a
generative model where one is persisting
active inference explicitly brings
action into that inference process and
it's the process by which dynamical
systems maximize their evidence for the
model of the world which they enact this
can occur by a system altering its
environment to fit expectations i.e
niche modification
so it's the difference between
the free energy principle merely saying
that persistent systems are going to be
isomorphic with those that have high
evidence for the world model which they
enact and then active inference as a
corollary process theory says
and the way that they're going to do
that is through
inference updating their internal model
or through action
which can be
just sort of like a flock of birds
action in the sky or it can be niche
modification like stigma g
nice thank you
um and then we can go on to thinking oh
stephen you have a comment to say
yeah just one piece here also sort of
flags up for me is the the use of the
word model because we talk about their
own model of the world and yet um
often we think of models as something
that we've created in the world you know
on a piece of paper and things like that
so again there's a sort of ontological
challenge in the sense that
it's it is kind of like a self model but
it's
it's it's a self model that's not a
representation
um so um but our language is kind of
couched in our history
um so anyway i think that might be
something that sort of resurfaces and
have to kind of
keep restating because people might have
this representational
kind of inbuilt
way of
you know those metaphors are quite
embedded so it's hard for people to
necessarily switch to what it means to
move away from representation
representational approaches
i have one question as well
the reason why we're talking about
active inference and free energy
principle in this paper so
avo
what
does
active do for this paper are there other
contender theories in the game how else
are people trying to take a unified
approach to studying
the specifics and the generalities of
states
so the um
the approach i have i define as an
active inference with the n
between parenthesis it's a synthesis
between what is said by an activist and
what is said back to influence theorists
the core framework is inactive i'm
interested in um
characterizing states uh
state societies
as a network of constraints so as uh
slow processes
that are
exist at the holy scale
uh not with the individual not between
individual but in some sense over
individual
and that
shapes the activity of individuals so as
to maintain itself that's the core
argument society is our organism but now
if i want to get there i need uh some
strong instincts
i if i need to get there in if i need to
formalize the role of states which are
at core information processing machines
in it i need to formalize in a struggle
in a stronger sense the relation between
um
public synchronization basic
authorization and epistemic states and
that is precisely what active influence
does
so i need uh the two
uh i need elective uh
formalism the native approach and i need
active influence formalism to
make the link between the
ecological activity of states
as an international process and the
body the
constraints that actually consists
that actually statistics consist in
[Music]
nice thank you
we can i guess move on to
uh thinking through other minds
um stephen did you have a comment just
one other comment as i was interested by
the um you know you're using the term
constraints
so
and in active inference is sometimes
thought of as the higher level processes
are in some ways constraining the
behavior of lower level processes rather
than necessarily dictating them so
they're you know it's look like i'm
doing the faster jig
and someone's just
slowing me down a little bit um
and so on so
yeah just curious that that word
constraints has brought in because often
people think of
you know intelligence is all about doing
things and
you know not constraining things so
anyway just curious about that
yep that's related to synergetics hawken
not bucky and about like a wave and a
ripple like the wave constrains where
the ripple can go the faster
fluctuations are constrained by the
slower ordering parameters
so here we have thinking through other
minds
and this
is another body of work which we won't
spend a ton of time on but
for
organisms that are making generative
models of their niche
sometimes that niche contains other
organisms such as their self
and it matters how those other organisms
also include generative models of
oneself so thinking through other minds
is describing how in a shared epistemic
niche shared informational niche with
shared salience cues for example
that two different agents are able to
coordinate
because they are thinking through each
other's minds like if i put up my hand
then blue will think that i want to
speak
so it's sort of like a little bit of a
theory of mind but with more of a act
imp flavor
so both like the idea of constraint and
this concept of thinking through other
minds bring me back to mike levin's
paper the computational boundary of the
self because of of the nested like
cognitive cones right and when he kind
of talked about it he talked about you
know the the higher order or like the
larger level the higher level organism
um or collective constrains the behavior
of like the the individual um like sub
level collectives um so that was kind of
this idea of constraint and and then
also um like thinking through other
minds like specifically we talked about
um
how
connections between
cells individuals but the connections
that that essentially breed
information sharing so so when you have
like a shared informational niche that
enables this this process kind of of
thinking through other minds where you
think more as a collective and so that
expands the cognitive boundary of the
self to then include other you know
individuals within that cognitive
boundary stephen
yeah and that ties into the work of andy
clark and uh the extended mind so
there's a
um so the way that that gets uh there's
there's a bit of um talk about how do
you think about that extension happening
and how much is it an extension of the
individual and how much i suppose is
what's being talked about here is how
much does
what has been extended start to become
its own
sort of cognitive agent
nice and maybe very appropriately avail
has returned and we are moving on to
talk about
niche construction and i think um avel
might have
a lot to say about the niche and its
role in
extending the cognitive boundary um so
maybe do you want to give us a few a few
insights into can we help us think
through your mind
modify the audio visual i'm not sure
what i could say about the niche
sorry modify the audio visual niche of
our joint
well that's attention
we modified the niche i will actually
actually within english i don't know
anyway um
i can't change your model of the niche
this is not what i'm going to do
i think
i'm not trying to do that activity at
least uh whatever um
so the there is body of work in
biology
uh evolutionary biology
which is centered on how organisms
modify
their direct environment
in a way that somehow fits their
their ecological needs
so a typical example is how beavers will
be
dumb source to get i i honestly don't
know what beavers get out of them but
they get something
and
the basic arguments uh in the um
thinking through of the minds uh
framework is that the way humanifier
niche has a cognitive value it's
externalized expectations
and
by analyzing expectations it allows
expectations to synchronize between
individuals
and
it's
there is a very clear
analogy or identity between
once you accept there is a cognitive
value in a niche construction as the
externalization of expectations
there is a very clear analogy and even
identity between uh niche construction
and excellent cognitions beaver are just
extending uh their cognition
their expectations the domain of the
world that
somehow participates
to the fact that they um
they live they keep on leaving and
understanding the world
so
there is a pretty basic way in which an
organism can expand
the
extent of the world the domain
which is operationally closed and which
participates actively in their
maintenance
and
this is basically
what's
there is to be found in this
construction by shaping their niche
organism shapes
their world they shape
their cognition they shape
their body
and
i'm not sure
i'm trying to give a general insight in
uh initial section and how it relates
but i'm not sure
how
relevant it is because i'm not sure what
is the point that is to be made
followingly
just that niche construction is an
important mechanism of
extended cognition like the recent
stigmargy models show that individuals
don't need to carry on board or
internally the entire cognitive
apparatus they only need to know how to
interact and potentially modify a niche
and then also i think this is important
when we're talking about
cities and so on and states because
our niche can as per thinking through
other minds include other
others like us
or distant from us but also it includes
the abiotic niche so climate change and
resource utilization those are niche
modifications there are some radioactive
mountains
that have been niche modified and so it
it provides a continuity
between
the kinds of ecological changes that
humans make
with the cognitive approach to
ecosystems and so that's why it's a very
rich framework to build off
so i just want to read this quote from
the paper really quick and then and then
stephen will come to your comment so it
says as stated previously the network of
constraints defining the structural
identity of basic life needs not be
printed in flesh it only needs to
influence faster processes so as to
continually recreate itself
and there the references for this are
there on the slides if you care to probe
further it says such constraints can be
embedded in the informationally rich
sociocultural niche which enable the
human ecology by affording adaptive
coordination and the development of
complex skills and i i think one of the
the main things that um this paper does
and uh feel free to correct me if i'm
wrong but it kind of takes the idea of
cumulative cultural evolution
and
brings the niche into this as a
cognitive extension
so i think that's one of the key moves
made here
basically i know a cultural revolution
uh i have known revolution for like five
years or so actually in france for one
year only so cultural relationships so i
see things and i'm currently writing a
paper on uh that could be integrated on
reductionism in cultural
and the fact is cumulative cultural
evolution in cultural revolution
is the replacement of low fitness
variants by high fitness variants
within a variant i mean of cultural
tokens that are implemented within minds
our behavior because there is not a
strong ontology on what the replicator
is in cultural evolution
and
a basic inside
world to convey is that
culture does not stop in the brain
culture does not certainly does not stop
in uh individuated cultural cocaines
and
one of the goal of the paper is to show
that social revolution it has analyst
extension uh our intention i don't know
uh
it does it exists uh not only within the
minds of individual and within uh the
verbal effects of cultural tokens it
exists
[Music]
instructors that are not apprehensible
uh by an individual
and that are not entailed by any
specific cultural token
hence the holism
thanks thank you stephen
[Music]
yeah also bringing that beaver example
is
to some extent the beaver constructs a
dam and to some extent maybe it grows a
dam
um maybe in the same you know so by
adding pieces it's it's growing
something a bit um and at what point
does it
sit stand back and say oh that
move that one a bit to the left move
that a little bit to the right and sort
of
improve the construction and how much is
it an evolving process
i suppose there's also the idea that
once something has grown
and it's changed the niche
um something else
you know just like the brain effectively
has to grow before it can do its
thinking um so maybe there's something
about
how these structures have grown
and been constructed so i don't know i
won't i'm just mentioning that
awesome thank you um i guess uh maybe we
kind of got ahead of our of ourselves uh
talking about niche modification and
cultural evolution um i love this
picture because it really uh shows like
kind of um how much we have offloaded
our our cognitive selves into the niche
environment like we don't need to know
how to use directions or what
restaurants are good or we don't need to
know actually any of that anymore
because it's all like riding around with
us in a smart phone in our pocket all
the time um so so we've just put put our
brain we've offloaded all of the
cognitive capacity of our of our brain
or at least a good portion of it so what
do we think about now what makes me
think about that always um it says in
the paper we claim that niche
modification is critical
for cumulative cultural evolution and
advancements such as writing allow
active inference to occur between agents
and stigmatic cues embedded in the niche
although
did i say what you did i write what you
just said
okay
what i want you to note is that what you
described the way we offload the
information on our social analytical and
technological
environments is the classical uh
collective brain picture which is
entailed by uh
mostly um void which has shown in
handwritten of cumulative cultural
evolution
uh what i want to show is that uh
together step beyond
we do not only have a self that is
augmented by
environmental cues there is a self
outside ourselves there is uh things
that shape social life and that are not
their agency that shape social life and
that is not human that is institutional
so that's the step beyond the collective
brain in the vanilla a collective brain
view which is maybe an anti-collective
brain there is
actually such a thing as a connective
brain starts an image and we can study
it
well we can study it now through
wikipedia and the internet like our
network of the collective brain steven
yeah it's interesting as well in terms
of
we have all this extended information
but
there's this there's a very good book
called the paradox of choice
so the the thing is we have all this
information but you still have to do an
action policy
on what to do
and the challenge is you can have so
many you know it's like going to the
supermarket and you know you can buy
50 different types of olive oil
okay it's just olive oil at the end of
the day but now you've got to choose
between 50 and you've got you know so
this there's a sense of abundance but
there's also a need for an action policy
which is of course what active influence
talks about um that ultimately it's not
the volume of information that's going
to be
the game it's the ability to
act
and uh inappropriate ways um and make
sense of how to be in your niche so
that's kind of interesting
awesome thank you
um so we are gonna move on um we're
gonna go into the next section embodied
intelligence in nested minds but but
just to quickly
summarize here like what was the main
the brought up in the introduction so
we've gone through the keywords but just
to clearly just state it out autonomous
systems are defined by a set of
processes that create and sustain their
identity they embody their understanding
and adaptive abilities within their
physical structure they enact a model of
their world and seek to maximize
evidence for this model through active
inference
and they can maximize model evidence
through modification of their niche so
just to kind of sum up what an
autonomous system is and what where we
are at this point and then we'll move on
to um
discussing embodied intelligence in
nested minds
so a quote from the paper it says uh
here we argue that innovations are
instead an emergent property of our
species cultural learning abilities
applied within our societies and social
networks our societies and social
networks act as collective brains we
outline how many human brains how many
human brains which evolved primarily for
the acquisition of culture together
beget a collective brain oh this isn't
actually from from the thinking like a
state paper this is from the innovation
in the collective brain paper
and this framework this collective brain
framework grounds the study of
intelligence in the way that an organism
maintains structural autonomy and allows
the formal assessment of the collective
brain hypothesis so the collective brain
hypothesis has been
put forward but not formally assessed up
until this point avail do you want to
talk a little bit more about that
because i probably just botched it
about how the collective brain pathogens
is not commonly assessed
yeah
so
in cultural evolution you have
what i'd say is the dominant theory is
gen coevolution uh gene culture
qualification theory
which is basically centered on how um
we have cultural variants that have an
adaptive role and there are a set of
cognitive bias
or cognitive mechanism but actually
cognitive bias uh bias actually actually
that help us identify what are the most
adaptive cultural variants and this uh
has a feedback effect on gene selection
which has an effect on cultural
selection and
basically all of your interpretation is
until the process of
a convolutional process between a
genetic and cultural
evolutionary information
processes
and
the fact is
there are claims there are numerous
claims in the literature that
there is some sort of collective
computation that you entered our
corrective cognition that is entailed by
this so there is if i remember well uh
henry and mata krishna who wrote the um
innovation in the collective brain paper
and there is i think boyd and um
svaldino
boyd which is
basically one of the two founders of the
initial formalism and smart dino which
is
one of the most competitively study a
member of the current literature that
wrote a paper on a collective cognition
no
collective comp distributed computation
because revolution has discrete
computation i don't know neglect data
but it's
uh i want to accentuate it a lot it's
words like they have a model of
individual bias
in a selection
and they have a narrative interpretation
of this somehow in telling some kind of
computation and there is
nothing in between there is a few paper
of
less introductors that's kind of
interested in the convolution of
social networks and cultural variants
access and smaller to name them
there is
literally not one paper that explains
how is this supposed to be cognition
what are the mechanisms what is the
cognitive architecture there is nothing
on it
uh or it's marginal and i did not heard
of it
and
the goal of the paper uh
is to basically explain how we can grant
a view of connective mechanisms that are
entitled by the social cultural networks
and structural constraints that are
embedded within a society
and that's it's not a model because
uh to build a full causal model of any
brain or organism is not
tractable but it's to prove that it's uh
meaningful
it's a
there is a positive way in which we can
model societies as or at least process
within societies as a collective form of
cognition
and a key example of this is the state
because we have access to the mechanisms
we have access to different papers with
which they understand and predict and
control reality
[Music]
awesome that's a perfect i think
transition into the next slide
do you want to read this first daniel
this paper uses the framework described
to illustrate that the co-evolution of
top-down control and cultural niche
construction enabled the inversions of
the city-state complex and how these
collective organizations maintain
structural autonomy
awesome thank you
and so that's kind of the
the summary i say of the of the section
the embodied intelligence and nested
minds uh section does anybody want to
give a thought or we can go on to the
next section
just what you just said about how we
know the mechanism level of the state
um
i'm thinking
we see its neurotransmitters and its
action selection
policies
so it's like
every system has advantages and
disadvantages for its study
this is one where many of the key
features
are designed and so it's a lot more like
investigating the connections of a
program that was written
rather than the potentially like map
territory debates over like what is the
bacteria really doing are we really
measuring the bacteria but it's like we
know how certain processes in the state
happen
but not all of them and citizens usually
don't know
steven
yeah so following on to what daniel said
a quick question in a way is
how
much you
may be trying to have a sort of a
realist approach on the idea of the
brain or being a
brain or how
how much is it an instrumental tool or a
metaphor so be curious as
you know you take that correlation
because you've got brain you've got mind
you've got intelligence you've got
extended cognition
is it that you are really wanting to
make it say that is like a brain that's
kind of
in
enacting its own
action policies or
um so that would be that might be
helpful
so i think actually like maybe we should
hold that to the end section from the
from the because i think we're going to
get more into how is a city like a brain
um as we get closer to the end of this
contextualization we'll save it for dot
one and dot two because we'll cover just
the background here but it's a very good
question
yeah very good um it's going to provoke
a lot of discussion so that's why i'm
like well maybe we should get through
the rest of the rest of the
talk going on first
so um
it is
so we're moving on now to the deep
history of cities and states
uh here is another quote from the paper
uh stephen do you want to read this for
us
yes okay
cultural niche construction
allowed humans to alter their social
cognitive ecology
in a way that allowed extensive
functional specialization and the
evolution of supra
individual agency through mediating
institutions
that makes me think about the evolution
of functional specialization in ant
colonies
and it's like
you can't have the super specialized
task you know you can't have somebody
who specializes on just sourdough bread
until there's somebody else who can help
them with some other tasks
and that's the economic inspiration for
why they call that process in ant's
division of labor
downstream of adam smith 1776 the
economic division of labor and the
candidate maker and the shoemaker and
all of that so once you have a lot of
people living together they can
specialize in a new way there are new
institutions needy needed to mediate
and that results in more being different
i love how daniel like says ants and
gets like giddy and excited
a stephen
yeah and i noticed this term super
individual so there's kind of this
um i suppose in the anchor you think of
the queen but in in our world we we have
these
and actually i've been thinking about a
lot of this myself in terms of how we
relate to these bigger scales so this
idea of a supra individual or
supra
collective
ties into the idea of the state you know
because
you know we think of you know
the word state is actually used
literally in the united states to be
you know a region but there is an idea
that is trying to maintain something so
um that term i think is a is a useful
one to sort of put out and uh
and that is super individual agency so
that ties it into active inference in a
in an interesting way um
it would be interesting to know the term
socio-cognitive ecology it's not one
i've heard before
in quite that way
so i don't know
that could be something just to just to
maybe ground that term
in this context
well we can return to it and i added the
book cover for leviathan
with the person made up of other people
awesome thank you
uh
so um
in this section of the paper avelle
explains how state niche
niche construction depended on
serial monoculture uh the technology of
writing
material infrastructure uh dense
sentiment dense settlements
and engineering societies from the top
down as documented in seeing like a
skate seeing like a state by scott
um avail do you have a few maybe words
to say about this i mean more than the
brief kind of overview i just gave
so i'm not sure identified a key uh
subject like on the um
importance on the uh morphogenesis of uh
states from a social scientific
perspective
just we're just talking about state
niche construction like what what did
that depend on
all of the things
um
but the career states is um
i think we could have a lot of
definitions uh their campaigns it i
think it's okay it is said in certain
tenses that it is uh
essentially a monopoly of on legitimate
violence
so if there is a group of men
that has weapons and that has the
exclusive rights to use it and that this
right is
probably accepted it is a state
uh i'm mostly interested in the mode of
operation of a state so for me it's a
chain of command basically it's an
emissive systems that
makes people do things
so these those two definitions they
entail
the loss of human autonomy then tell
that you have at least a subset of
humans that
are constrained to follow the laws laws
that are uh extremely imposed
so that's in clear deviation from what
is done say in iroquois society where
at least by the personal contact
mostly no one has the power to coerce
anyone else and any decision is grounded
on rational debates
so this is not what a state is like a
state is when you are a guy with the
biggest bird and you can say okay you go
kill this person because i want to i
want this weapon and
um
you have a
[Music]
definition of the states that's
uh sorry
your definition of the state there is
that is uh grounded in the
sub-brain i'm not sure when it initiates
i think it's with leviton which i did
not read but basically that the state is
a central actor that has power um on
anyone
which is um sorry of
chats
things
um
so state is uh something that has power
on anyone it's not tied to a specific
individual
so that entails the capability for a set
of for institution or a set of
individuals to
basically coerce other people to do
things
and this entail
for example enough at least a north
centralization of resources for other
people to not flee
or enough imbalance in wealth for other
people to get to you even though they
know it will strip them of their
autonomy so it's about the grounding on
which the literature that project
literature on um states and state
emergence is written
and this entails agriculture uh trade a
lot of ways for basically wealth to be
centralized and powerful people to be
able to constrain everyone else
awesome and that like speaks very well
to um how
states get a grip on their subjects and
themselves um and what is the the common
grounding maybe that um
is used to get like to get a
heterogeneous
um
understanding of states oh sorry
emergency alert ah
your attention please your attention
please
update in action policy requested from
the state
exactly exactly so so now states get a
grip on us through like our our
cognitive offloading into the knee
strike
um stephen did you want to say something
yeah i mean this also speaks to that
challenge of being able to get a grip on
things which are beyond the adjacent
scale like that you know they're trying
to get you know they have to use they
have these technologies they can reach
out to everyone but at the same time
it's kind of
they can't easily get a grip
so there's um there's some interesting
points there around um
you know because there's a few scales
between us and the state right
um
and that's that's interesting
and technological development
like
little tiny chips that track where you
move
that makes it a little easier to get a
grip on where somebody is moving
so it's a co-evolution with the states
and technology going back to
agriculture and writing and ledgers and
now we're in a new phase of ledgers from
zero one two three
nice stephen
yeah and of course the challenge is that
they get a grip on what you're doing but
they their influence is about why you're
doing it
decontextualized so
they think someone's
doing x
or y and
it may be wildly different
you know they may be underestimating the
risk or they may be radically
overestimating the risk of behavior
awesome so i'm going to just flip
through these next few slides
so
uh dense settlements the what the
function of the dense settlement did was
allowed for economic codependency and we
talked earlier about the functional
specialization that was like you know
necessary for this economic
co-dependency and it also facilitated um
the development of
nested social communities uh um and
daniel wrote is their scaling
relationship here and i think we have to
wait and address that maybe in the in
the dot one
um
and uh moving on it says enforcing state
control over urban systems
mandates building acceptance into the
population and this is like how do you
let the state be in charge of you how do
you grant grip to the state
and this is
the people must perceive competency in
the authoritarian
regime and there's a redistribution of
wealth like for example paying taxes
and also symbolic legitimacy which is
achieved through the church
um largely or maybe maybe there's other
ways but but was in in the in the early
development of cities and states largely
um religious based
so what um
there's a lot of things that that we've
talked about so that tie into
formation of cities and states and it's
large-scale coordination collective
identity
crop redistribution which i thought was
interesting like some people grow it
some people eat it some people take it
some people sell it
and then the functional specialization
specialized rules
and the control of the money and the
flow of the money so all these things
together
unify to give a state grip and allow
this kind of top-down control
is is there any comments on that or if
not we can move on to the next section
just that if those are the necessary and
sufficient features
when there's a crisis of competency or
distribution of wealth or symbolic
legitimacy
what is that forbode
avail do you have a an answer i'm sure
waiting and waiting in the wings
yes uh the answer is basically uh a
structural
structural demographic theory which is
central side results in clevelandics
which basically
states afford the possibility for the
elites to ignore
the social
maintenance and just capture wealth
and
when they do too much it causes
political instabilities so
and this entails uh fluctuating um
protecting cycles of integration and
distribution
in states developments and by the way
we in the sense of france the us and
likely
global capitalism are in a phase of
disintegration which
uh needs
which entails that we have uh you don't
need to understand how to organize
outside or
in spite of
administration and to understand where
they come from
cool
so we're going to move into the last
section of the paper which is from the
urban metabolism to
the collective mind
and we're going to go back to the main
question of the article which was what
kind of intelligence is displayed by
city-state systems and how is it
embodied within their structure
and uh maybe stephen do you want to read
this quote from the paper
yes
okay so answering this question in terms
of inactive inference entails revisiting
our accounts of the urbanization
dynamics as the results of city-state
systems
actively managing to get a grip on their
world ie
minimize their expected variational free
energy
cool and there are a couple more um
quotes from this section uh that we can
move on to
daniel do you want to read this first
one here
basic autonomy is indeed formally
defined as operational closure or more
precisely the capability of a network of
constraints to canalize faster processes
like metabolic flows into maintaining
and recreating itself
i like that's kind of a twist on the
kantian organism concept the
teleological definition the organism is
like the level it makes sense at
and this takes a more operational and
mechanistic approach towards closure of
mechanism and
uh
constraints and autopoiesis rather than
merely end directedness which doesn't
immediately suggest a mechanism
and then
since the material and socio-cultural
landscapes of urban systems canalize
human activities so as to maintain
itself
the process of urbanization clearly
intains the constitution of cities as
basic life
food comes in waste goes out
city's alive
awesome and i love this picture of like
the elephant is the city um sir did you
want to say
i want you to something out that
the first point you made is that um with
the mountable and moisture definition or
my
account of them is a twist on the
conscience idea that organism is the
level
at which it makes sense
and it's basically the movement that
monteville and monsieur and moreno make
because
uh in activism at first it's surrounded
in concertal philosophy and feminine
energy
um
[Music]
this this is the grounding in which uh
varela and maybe machrena i'm not sure
articulated uh the view that cognition
is in fact grounded in life
and what uh
mostly people and the basque center for
life sciences i think it's called try to
do is to mechanize it to personalize it
to ground it into specific uh chemical
biochemical processes so it's you
precisely captured what this account is
meant to do
awesome
and good good job inferring daniel
based on based on the um you know
stigmatic cues left in the niche uh and
and we can move on to a couple more
quotes from the paper um
this is one that really resonated with
me and it's paraphrasing jablonka and
lam in 2006 this paper that's here the
evolution of information in the major
transitions
says a full-fledged evolutionary
transition typically entails the
emergence of new forms of information
systems mediating regulation at the
collective level and or the heritability
of collective traits
and then another quote from the paper
is also taken from this gaudian crawl
paper in 2014
it says the emergence of city-states
with their professional classes and
their mediating institutions
based on writing technologies constitute
a clear case of such a transition
especially in the case of the late
agricultural civilizations and i i
totally get this and also it really
speaks to how stigmatic cues left in the
niche environment can can contribute to
the formation of our collective brain i
mean writing like we can leave stigmatic
cues for generations yet to follow and
some writing in stone right like so this
is like still we can read it many many
many many ages and generations later
which i thought that was really uh
poignant stephen
yeah one thing i'd be interested in in
terms of the state is um
how much different
areas of society or the state
are trying to achieve similar types of
outcome
so when there's um and when there's i
mean we've just had that case of um
that video of
a
cortez being murdered and uh you know so
like within
the state you have
internal conflicts you know within
within the state itself um but also
how much does the people at different
scales have to be aligned or how much
will the state itself kind of do what
states do so to speak as its own mind
awesome thanks daniel
yeah i agree about
not every single action in the state
necessarily being the same like if you
looked at the body you said well no
we're supposed to be making glucose why
are there cells that are breaking it
down or like
there can be sections that are doing
processes that seem directly opposite to
each other
but that can be part of a broader
regulatory process so
it
brings into question you know what are
the official
processes versus the things that are in
the gray zone of the state
and how do we go from this model into
more useful forms
nice thanks
um and so we can move now to another
quote from the paper that is from
paraphrasing
this paper that we actually just did in
a recent live stream um how to count
biological minds by
matthew sims
and in
in the thinking like a state paper it
says if the nested hierarchy of
regulation systems enables adaptive
behavior at the system scale it
effectively enacts a collective mind
regardless of
whether system components retain their
cognitive ability
and this speaks back to what we were
saying earlier about the the top level
kind of constraining the lower levels
like maybe there's like a uh
once you contribute to the collective
then you know you've contributed to
something greater than yourself and your
your own cognitive ability perhaps
doesn't matter so much
any thoughts on that or we can move on
to some more topics from the paper
daniel do you want to read this
quote
the closest analog
of our intuitive picture of a mind in
urban systems is their most disembodied
mechanism for adaptive regulation
administration
indeed just like neuronal cognition
it entails the top-down regulation by a
specialized population with the help of
a specific purpose information system
it makes me think about those tubes that
they used to put the physical
packages in and send them and now
they're special information channels but
you better be listening when that
channel calls
so that's like futurama like they have
like i mean the bureaucracy like the
administration and i mean administration
i love this quote from the paper i do
think like administration is totally
like disembodied from like reality and
bureaucracy is like so imposing but like
in the futurama they all have like you
know it's like space age modern
transmission like you could just click
docusign on the internet and like yet
they're using like tubes literally like
to send the things off um and it takes
seven years to get approval or something
ridiculous like that but it like it does
work like that right bureaucracy is is
kind of crazy
this next quote says the institution of
state-sponsored legal codes affords a
way to directly transcribe
administrative expectations into
individual minds rule of law is
therefore a core tool by which states
create their world through building the
basis of their own intelligent behavior
into their socio-cultural niche and this
is brilliant right like just yesterday
my landlord called the codes officer um
because my neighbors have weeds right
like i know they're not allowed to have
weeds it's beyond the expectation of of
like you know our neighborhood that
nobody has weeds and everyone knows that
this is the expectation some people
don't maintain their weeds and we all
have the right and duty and obligation
to you know impose that on our niche
environment daniel
um so the uh
expectations the normative expectations
a lot of laws are like you know it shall
be within two weeks after this giving
notice that this happens so their
expectations and then they're called
codes and so maybe think about
predictive coding
and it's like we can predict that this
technology is going to be used this way
so i know it's not exactly what people
mean with the neural rate codes etc with
predictive processing predictive coding
but
laws are
normative they're saying what should
happen and that helps
behave as expected you want to be on the
right side of the road driving in the
u.s so that's like an expectation and
then it becomes an intersubjective
preference that is sponsored by the
state so it's just kind of cool again
showing points of contact between
people's day-to-day life
and their intuitive explanations for how
these systems work and then it's like
yes we have an ontology that picks up
right with you
and then
goes a little further than you might
have expected to
awesome serval
yes that's exactly
the idea
knows until the externalization of
expectations the fact that they are
normative is i think
incidental accidental it's a phenomenon
to their core role which is to shape
behavior
you have a project in
legal studies i don't know how you call
that
which is called i think homogeneous
ridiculous or homogeneous or some
closely associated formulation which has
a behavioral approach to bone
and
we need to do that more
yeah sounds good
um so we just have some summary um
quotes maybe from the paper and to kind
of summarize the ideas that were
presented here daniel do you want to
read one or some of these
okay i'm just picking which one i would
want to read i think the second one is a
lot like what we were just talking about
with
the state defining expectations and then
modifying its own niche that operational
closure to
implement those expectations lest it
dissolve
then i i like this top quote our notion
of intelligence is based upon active
inference a scale-free framework
applying to any system with individuated
boundary states
and then it's like
even the word state is upon as avail
pointed out before it's at being state
and french and we talk about internal
external blanket states boundary states
that sounds like it's going to be at the
boundary of the empire
and then this is what it looks like to
apply active inference to a real system
to go from a sort of bayesian graph
boundary notion to being like well what
if that boundary state
country
was
intermediating and insulating between
these other two so i like how even the
word state
comes into play i like that i i really
like that too and i like that like that
that's kind of a play on um like the
first in particular physics like
specific particular physics but also
like physics as related to a particle um
and and the idea of a state actually
something when i was proofreading this
paper was like you know i know that
you're talking about like city states
but it's not
immediately obvious to the reader that
like you might want to say like city
states to kind of flesh that out like
from the get-go because it is it can be
such a play on word right it's a
boundary state it's a blanket state it's
an active state it's a you know city
state daniel maybe one other thing we
can talk about in the dot one and two is
states as we know them
are
new
and so it's only been a few generations
like your great great great grandparents
that's a long time ago it's a lot of
tacos ago but
it's a blink of the eye
in terms of evolution
and in terms of deep history
and so even pre westphalia that was not
so long ago
and there's so many
world traditions and so just
realizing that we're in a very
non-stationary moment
with the development and the
implementation of states
it's really important because it can be
easy to be like oh it's a grind all the
states in the u.n and you know 50 states
in the u.s it's like
even 70 years ago there weren't that
many states in the u.s and there was
different countries in the world so
things are changing it just sometimes
it's at a different time scale which
makes sense because they're bigger and
slower entities than we are
cheval
i want to point out two things first the
pawn is not intended but no i will claim
it is and no one will check
um the second is that
the received you is that
states emerge with agriculture it is
what gordy and kroll said in the paper i
cited
um it is not accurate or we don't know
whether it separates uh you have a
pretty good single review of the
literature of the
state emergence and the fact is we do
not know what human societies were like
before written history we do not know
so i
and most importantly it's um
something uh grabber and one grow to a
leading anthropologist in historical
apology like to uh rave about
uh there are kinds of conversations that
are authoritarian there are kinds of
transactions that are not so even with
if we are
signs of i don't know great ritual
states or anything we don't know whether
those kind of organization
were like what we know today because uh
western national states are extreme in
kind of extractive and corrective
behavior but they are shaped by war
within europe and between europe and um
colonial colonialized uh countries
uh so i prefer i much prefer to ground
uh the history in which i talk uh in
europe and history in a modern history
after westfalia after the birth or
in the roots of the birth of the
national states because
it's pretty hard
to talk about the roots of sumerian
states we need to do so because
those are states we need to do so if we
want to talk about what states are but
if you want to talk about what our
states are we need to go uh in west
faria we didn't mean not to go in summer
or egypt or whatever
so just to kind of play off of that um
extractive and corrosive behavior
and that states are often born out of
war um something that you mention in the
paper but um i i don't think maybe gets
enough um
attention is the concept of shared
identity because in this shared identity
like that's what makes us faction off
into our own state we're going to divide
and become something new
and daniel was saying how we have so
many states now so many more states than
we've ever had before and this like
factionalism and we all have like this
distinct identity is this going to breed
more war or is every state going to
become so small because they'll just
faction and keep dividing i mean you can
get something the most homogenous human
culture you can imagine and they will
find something to divide them so so is
this good is it bad if it we keep
dividing is it going to be like a
homogeneous like bunch of sub-factions
or is it just going to lead to like more
division and more war
um
if i discuss that it will take a lot of
time
i understood this session was excellent
we are much off track
definitely
we'll save it for the dot one
um
okay so moving on uh the collective mind
does not directly emerge from
inter-individual interactions but from
slower evolving dynamical constraints
which supervene on but do not reduce to
human activity
therefore the proper scale of analysis
of collective cognition is an integrated
activity of entire urban systems and
should more specifically be grounded in
the broader processes by which they
maintain and reproduce their structural
identity understood as an operationally
closed set of constraints underlying
their metabolic cognitive and ecological
activity
you know replace urban with
brain body
just you could say the same exact thing
the brain the body have to be an
integrated unit
finally
blue what does it mean to think like a
state
i'm going to put your overlay over the
video so it'll look like you're a state
go for it
the cognitive activity of states is
defined mechanically by the standardized
administrative systems they use to
understand and manipulate their world
and functionally by their drive to build
and enact grip over the material and
sociocultural niche
so there it is the question the answer
we made it through from a to z and i
like it's not what is it like to be
a state it's not the nagel 54 what is it
like to be a bat
this is more of a cognitivist
interpretation
that
helps us actually
potentially find useful
ways you know
like
i don't want to do a you know in in x
country
you grip the state
people can kind of write their own jokes
on that theme
nice um and we can just think about what
maybe these
questions lead to maybe what a good
understanding of this work might enable
um avail mentioned earlier the
necessity for this understanding because
of the the kind of divide divided
space that we're in right now
what are the next steps for the fep and
active inference
what are the goals what are you still
curious about if you want to participate
in either of the discussion videos get
in touch with us we would love to have
you on to talk about these ideas in more
detail do you guys have any closing
thoughts
yeah just in dot
one let's
dive in and open some threads take some
notes
in dot two let's see where we go maybe
somebody would like to
pick up on one of those threads or apply
one of these ideas and say oh i was
working on a history of my region and so
i wanna
see how i can apply that
so we applied active inference to get
thinking like a state and then how do we
apply
thinking like a state
for
something else whatever it is that
somebody is interested in seeing
avel thank you for coming and kind of
guiding us through our contextualization
video it's always a pleasure do you want
to have the final word
i don't know and it is anything smart to
say so
yes but
these are the words
the paper does speak for itself uh quite
brilliantly i will say
all right authors who come on dot zero
are the best
no it's all good thanks for joining blue
and facilitating see you later survival
and thanks also to stephen so hope to
see you all in the dot one
with the dot two or beyond so bye
bye
[Music]